emergency crews are racing to evacuate
tens of thousands of people who live
downstream from a failing dam in
Northwest Puerto Rico the reservoir
behind the dam is swollen from heavy
rain left by Hurricane Maria Puerto Rico
is already struggling with no
electricity in the wake of the hurricane
Maria is blamed for at least six deaths
on the island an estimated 15,000 people
are in shelters and communications are
crippled 85% of Puerto Rico's cellphone
towers landlines and internet cables are
disabled david beg no is in the capital
San Juan David good morning good morning
as many as 70,000 people are living in
that area where the dam is failing as
you said in the northwestern portion of
the country in an area known as la
hitaka now the first alert went out
about 14 hours ago
buses were brought in to start
evacuating people out we're broadcasting
live this morning from our hotel in San
Juan it's one of the only places on this
island where you can get a good Wi-Fi
signal and that is enabling us to bring
the information to you but all you've
got to do is go about 20 minutes from
where we are here in the capital of San
Juan and you'll find flood water be
ready if we need to get you out San Juan
mayor Yulin crews waded through the
hardest hit streets of her city the
mayor handed out cold water at this
nursing home later she visited 93
year-old Marina Fernandez who's having
trouble with her vision and is alone her
home healthy it hasn't been able to
visit her since the hurricane hit it's
very difficult
it's it's unfathomable think of your
worst nightmare and there it is no power
anywhere in Puerto Rico no water we have
the reservoirs of drinking water have
been depleted diesel is very quickly
running out already residents are trying
to cope without power outdated and
fragile most of Puerto Rico's power
lines are above ground no match for
Maria
some families resorted to cooking
outside is this all one family a
flashlight was their only source of
light Ricardo Ramos runs the islands
power company what are we talking weeks
without power or months I think we're
gonna be talking about month if we go
back to history under a hurricane Google
it took six months to restore power to
everyone at this San Juan orphanage for
girls food and water are running out
sister Betty Iran for thought okay NSSE
thing we want to give them everything
they need but without food and water we
cannot give them anything already
seventy four billion dollars in debt the
challenge of rebuilding for Puerto Rico
will be daunting
I gotta get worse before they get better
we were told yesterday that some
commercial flights to the US mainland
were going to resume to key cities like
Miami New York's JFK and Philadelphia
but that didn't really happen in fact
people have been complaining that
they're having a really hard time
getting off the island and folks who are
trying to get here to bring relief aid
are also having a hard time Anthony the
good news is we've seen you more US
military and FEMA agents riding around
the island that is good news David big
no thanks so many people in distress
there in Puerto Rico